en cette tribune des médias publiée en
plein procès des attentats de 2015 un
appel à défendre la liberté d'expression
menacée
cette chère liberté qui trouve ses bases
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 est elle
aujourd'hui menacée et l ange est elle
en danger on en parle tout de suite avec
nos invités dominique pradalié bonsoir
vous êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
national des journalistes merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france avec
vous alexis poulain que l'on connaît
bien éditorialistes merci de répondre à
nos questions alors ce que je vous
propose avant de revenir sur l'appel de
cette soixantaine de médias français
pour la liberté d'expression
on va peut-être tout d'abord
s'intéresser à celle une tribune publiée
hier par une quarantaine de sociétés de
journalistes
c'était à propos du nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre et de la liberté
d'informer je vais le site et un feu
vert accordé par le ministre de
l'intérieur aux forces de l'ordre pour
empêcher les journalistes de rendre
compte pleinement des manifestations
alors ce matin gérald darmanin parle
d'un malentendu
le ministre de l'intérieur s'était t-il
fait mal comprendre alexis poulain non
ce matin il mentait sur les ondes d'une
radio nationale parce que si gérald
darmanin à leur manifestation ils
verraient que et bien les policiers
demandent la carte de presse souvent à
des journalistes pour les empêcher de
passer pour leur dire de rebrousser
chemin de ne pas filmer ce qu'il se
passe en or manifestation c'est déjà le
cas aujourd'hui et pourtant la carte de
presse n'est pas obligatoire elle n'a
rien à voir avec le droit d'exercer ou
pas cette profession de journaliste et
de faire son travail c'est à dire être
témoin est reportée ce qu'il se passe
dans les rues de notre pays la france
donc qu'on le laisse mentir sur une
antenne nationale très bien ça aurait
été bien que journaliste prépare
l'interview et le reprennent en dix ans
mais je ne comprends pas quel malentendu
soyons clairs alors cette loi n'a pas
lieu d'être
parce que les lois sont bien faites il
ya une loi d'ailleurs qui protège la
presse c'est loi de 1881 sur la liberté
d'informer qui est très bien faite qui
n'a pas être touchés et petit à petit on
voit bien que les lois d'exception
encore de cette liberté de la presse la
réduisent et fait en sorte que les
français s'habituent à avoir de moins
deux journalistes qui peuvent faire leur
travail c'est extrêmement grave parce
que derrière est bien celle équilibre
démocratique qui est en jeu c'est la
façon qu'ont les citoyens de s'informer
librement auprès de journalistes qui
sont fiables et qu'ils peuvent faire
leur travail librement
chaque année la france dégringole dans
le classement mondial de reporters sans
frontières est encore reporters sans
frontières est très gentil avec le
gouvernement français
entre les violences contre les
journalistes de la part des forces de
l'ordre
et ça arrive entre le contrôle des
journalistes entre la façon dont
certains médias ont été traitées avec
des perquisitions au sein de rédaction
tout ça est bien ça qui crée un très
mauvais climat
c'est extrêmement inquiétant et ça
devrait être normal
et bien non ce n'est pas normal la
pratique du pouvoir aujourd'hui en
france elle inquiète les journalistes et
heureusement ils se sont réveillés ils
ont fait cette tribune maintenant il va
falloir se lever encore plus fort et
empêcher le gouvernement d'aller plus
loin dans ses mesures liberticides vous
qui tenez les comptes dominique pradalié
il ya eu beaucoup de journalistes
notamment depuis un an avoir été
empêchée travaillé lors de
manifestations en france
eh bien nous comptons 1 plus de 200 plus
de 200 les journalistes qui n'ont pas pu
travailler correctement sur les
mouvements sociaux notamment des gilet
jaune mais jusqu'à la manifestation du
17 septembre dernier où deux nouveaux on
a embêté journalistes on les a mis en
garde à vue il y en a un qui a pris un
coup de poing directement de la part
d'une personne des forces de l'ordre
ça fait 200 e e quelques bavures peuvent
survenir dans ce type de manifestation
on l'a vu au cours des âges ce qui se
passe depuis 18 mois est une totale
impunité des forces de sécurité pour
empêcher juristes de travailler cibler
directement visé blaise est directement
menacée injurié leur matériel saisi leur
matériel et casser leur matériel de
protection confisquer les gardes à vue
tout ça sans qu aucune plainte
aucun signalement l'igpn
réussi à faire son chemin à ce jour et
je rejoins avec six poulains dans le
fait que la liberté de la presse
c'est la loi 1881 et que peu à peu un
ministre de l'intérieur après l'autre un
premier ministre après l'autre ses
forces de toutes les manières de
d'habituer les citoyens à ce que les
journalistes dont la mission est de les
informer soient tenus en laisse
nous disons donc non et nous sommes
ravis de voir que les sociétés de
journalistes ont fait quelques jours
après nous exactement la même analyse ça
prouve bien que toute la profession dit
non à cette espèce de manuels de
dressage pour journalistes alors outre
aux tribunes on le disait c'est cet
appel d'une centaine de médias pour la
liberté d'expression face aux menaces il
signe et publie une lettre une lettre
ouverte à nos concitoyens ils dénoncent
notamment les menaces de mort que
certains reçoivent parmi les signataires
on peut noter france télévisions rtl
la voix du nord le journal du dimanche
me nommant que regarder par exemple les
fps sollicité par charlie hebdo a choisi
de ne pas s'associer à la lettre ouverte
des médias ensemble défendons la liberté
la réactions consternées du snj afp
dominique travail et peut être à mon
justement sur ces médias mobilisés et ce
qu'on vient d'entendre
alors il n'est jamais trop tard pour
bien faire et l'ensemble des médias qui
ne s'est pas vraiment mobilisé à tout
instant pour servier dos le fait
aujourd'hui tant mieux la fp n'y est pas
eh ben c'est fort dommage et je trouve
que là il ya un manque est terrible
maintenant nous aurions aimé nous
aimerions toujours que ses employeurs de
journalistes qui ont tous été empêchés
de travailler par les forces de l'ordre
se soient mobilisés ou se mobilise
maintenant pour eux exigé que les
journalistes des rédactions de même que
l'esprit
journalistes puissent travailler
convenablement et exercer leurs missions
alexis poulain effectivement vous
partagez ce même mais ce même constat
que tous les médias ne se sont pas
forcément mobilisés pour cette tribune 1
contre eux le nouveau schéma du maintien
de l'ordre et la liberté d'informer ils
ont mis bien du temps oui trop de temps
je trouve
sachant que là il s'est vraiment le la
goutte d'eau déjà sur les violences
policières il a fallu des mois pour que
certains médias commencent à parler de
mes violences policières et et à
s'autoriser le terme est encore avec des
pincettes parfois il fallait surtout pas
utiliser le terme
je trouve que aujourd'hui il ya une
vraie hypocrisie de certains médias
propriété de grands groupes industriels
qui ne font pas un travail d'information
qui continue finalement d'être dans un
rôle de passe-plat d'organisation d'un
débat très policé où le gouvernement a à
peu près toujours raison fait toujours
bien les choses c'est pas le cas le
journalisme c'est porter la plume dans
la plaie s'est appuyé là où ça fait mal
c'était la critique sociale comme le
disait jaurès et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on est dedans un peu trop
un journalisme de connivence 1 journée
de cours
parce que bien certains attendent des
mannes financières ou bien des marchés
ou d'autres choses de la part des
rédactions il ya toujours l'indépendance
des réactions c'est ce qu'on dit
la rédaction est séparé de
l'actionnariat ça c'est sur le papier
mais il ya un problème bien sûr de
citoyenneté dans les médias qui doit
être résolu les médias appartiennent aux
citoyens c'est pas à quelques grands
patrons de se faire plaisir en ayant des
médias c'est aux citoyens maintenant de
s'investir alors ça coûte cher bien sûr
la presse ça coûte cher de s'informer de
nombreux biens que ce secteur est en
crise avec une précarisation
grandissante des jeunes journalistes qui
arrive sur le marché avec des titres qui
ont bien du mal à survivre les aides
d'état qui sont là avec bien tout le
côté l'ès qui va avec l'aide d'états
évidemment et puis des médias publics
d'information qui deviennent finalement
des médias de un peu comme le rtf qui
sont là surtout pour ne pas bousculer
typiquement l'interview de gérald
darmanin ce matin sur une radio
nationale publique
on aurait aimé que les journalistes
aient un peu plus de mordant pour lui
poser les questions qui fâchent
voilà moi je trouve que les journalistes
ont aussi un travail à faire les
citoyens ou bien sûr un travail à faire
pour défendre une presse indépendante et
libre et puis le gouvernement doit
arrêter maintenant
avec ces mesures liberticides mais je
pense pas qu'il va arrêter
malheureusement donc c'est à nous d'être
d'ailleurs c'est à tout le monde d'être
vent debout contre cette façon de renier
nos libertés de manière systématique
depuis les lois d'exception
dominique pradalié pour pour conclure le
mot de la fin pour rééquilibrer le la
capacité des rédactions à travailler en
toute indépendance
il ya une solution assez simple devant
laquelle avec beaucoup de lâcheté
plusieurs gouvernements ont refusé de
répondre
il s'agirait de reconnaître légalement
ce qu'est une équipe rédactionnelle et
de lui donner un certain nombre de
possibilités juridiques pour équilibrer
contre les actionnaires contre les le
marketing contre le partenariat ces
terrains qui minent ce travail et c'est
une solution assez simple mais il faut
un tout qui courage politique et ce
n'est pas le cas encore en ce moment un
grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci à vous
dominique pradalié je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
national des journalistes merci amour
avec six poulains éditorialistes